- We'll divide up.
If you are on the stools
or standing at the back
on this side, what would you
like to hear a rap about?
(audience shouting)
Jesus Christ.
(audience laughing)
Underwater basket weaving,
you may not believe this,
has been suggested on three
separate occasions before.
(audience laughing)
Because it's a reference to a--
(audience member shouting)
Yeah, it's a reference
to a Monty Python sketch,
which is why people say it.
What did you say at the back?
- [Audience Member] Star Wars planets.
- Star Wars planets?
Great, cool, did you have
a particular one in mind?
(audience laughing)
No, mate, you choose!
Fine (laughs), right.
Let's come to the, if
you are on the stools
or standing over on this side,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Bicycle pump.
- Bicycle pump, yeah!
Is that something you've had
to grapple with recently?
(audience laughing)
What do you use it, 'cause it's not just
for bicycles, is it?
It's for, like, sexy,
blowup ladies and stuff.
(audience laughing)
It is!
Okay, cool, so a bicycle
pump, Star Wars planets,
if you are on a chair but
you're on this half of the room,
what would you like a rap about?
What was that?
- [Audience Member] A staunchion.
- Well, you're on the front row,
so that's an irrelevant suggestion!
You said a "staunchion"?
So not a stanchion.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, that's it.
- A stanchion, okay, cool!
No, that's just different pronunciation.
That's just different.
The thing is, I know it's a different--
- [Audience Member] He's from Wales.
- He's from Wales?
Are you? I'm not gonna pick on him.
He's got quite big arms and
I'm tall, but I'm stringy.
So a stanchion, I don't even
think I know what that is.
It's a kind of upright
mast, is that right?
What is it?
(audience murmuring)
Like a vertical pole?
I think "upright mast" covers that, yeah!
(audience laughing)
Cool, good.
I like, that's the difference
between England and Wales.
"Upright mast," "vertical
pole," it's good!
(audience laughing)
You know, shut up, Australians!
You'd have been like,
"straight stick" (laughs).
(audience laughing)
Great, so a stanchion or a staunchion,
a bicycle pump, Star Wars planets.
If you're on a chair on
this side of the room,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Rapunzel with an Afro.
- Hmm!
(audience laughing)
If you didn't hear that
delightful suggestion,
it was "Rapunzel with an Afro."
I like it.
We'll take one final suggestion.
This can come from anywhere,
but make it really good.
- [Audience Member] A urinal cake!
- One second, urinal
cakes, that's pretty good.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] The ethics
of infant male circumcision.
- The ethics of infant
male circumcision, yeah.
(audience laughing)
I'm glad you clarified
male, as well, because
(audience laughing)
It's much less gross, really.
So urinal cakes or urinal cakes,
the ethics of male
circumcision, a stanchion,
Star Wars planets, a bicycle pump,
and what was our other one we had?
(audience murmuring)
Rapunzel with an Afro, okay!
That's one more than I usually take,
but I'm happy with that.
You may need to remind me,
six tend to slip my mind.
This, lovely people of the Aberdeen,
is gonna be a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on those suggestions,
never to be seen before,
never to be seen again,
and do not worry, it
will not be anywhere near
as atrociously, embarrassingly bad
as you are expecting a privately-educated,
middle-class white boy to be.
(audience laughing)
(audience member cheering)
Let's do this.
(chill music)
Where to begin?
Maybe yours, sir.
You're up front.
You violated the rule to give
your word, and that's fine.
(rhythmic frog croaking)
♪ Go on ♪
♪ It was forbidden for you to speak ♪
♪ But in this portion, the front row ♪
♪ You were like, nah, Chris, staunchion ♪
♪ Doesn't even matter
that he said it wrong ♪
♪ It's still the way that we
start the improvised song ♪
♪ A stanchion, yeah,
I stand to attention ♪
♪ It's an upright pole and I mention ♪
♪ I can tie my little horse to it ♪
♪ I can make sure the rope
reef knot round fits ♪
♪ Or a double loop, or
a little double shank ♪
♪ All of the Scout
training I have to thank ♪
♪ To know how to tie things to that pole ♪
♪ It's kind of boring,
but that's the goal ♪
♪ We start boring and
then we get much better ♪
♪ Piss in a urinal, make it wetter ♪
♪ But what is the problem ♪
♪ There's a mistake ♪
♪ If it smells so bad, add a urinal cake ♪
♪ If you don't have one, go and collect ♪
♪ You need to put it in,
'cause it refreshes the scent ♪
♪ You need to make sure it doesn't stink ♪
♪ And if you have no urinal,
just piss in the sink ♪
♪ If you did that, that's a real mistake ♪
♪ And never confuse it
for a birthday cake ♪
♪ Oh no ♪
♪ Put it on the little table ♪
♪ Jimmy comes along, he's
five years, he's able ♪
♪ To blow out the candles ♪
♪ He makes a wish ♪
♪ But sadly, he just gets
splattered with piss ♪
♪ He's like, Mum, what is this thing ♪
♪ I thought it was a pineapple ring ♪
♪ I got confused when I saw this ♪
♪ Don't worry, little Jimmy
boy, you'll adore this ♪
♪ Did you know, if you go for a wee ♪
♪ There's no foreskin
on your tiny pee-nee, ♪
♪ Why, well, ethically ♪
♪ In America, the country next to me ♪
♪ Where I live, 'cause I
live on the coast, anyway ♪
♪ They will get a little
boy and rip it all away ♪
♪ They will cut it off ♪
♪ Yeah, they can't resist ♪
♪ In Judaism, it's called a bris ♪
♪ They take a little knife
with a big cool guy ♪
♪ In a black cloak, yeah ♪
♪ We know the rabbis ♪
♪ And they don't really care
about the ethical problems ♪
♪ You used to have a foreskin,
but now you don't have one ♪
♪ Sorry, man, you must feel a real chump ♪
♪ So blow up more skin
with a bicycle pump ♪
♪ Insert the valve in
the bottom of your bell ♪
♪ Pump it up, pump it
up, pump it up well ♪
♪ Stepping on the thing
and you push down hard ♪
♪ Got a bicycle with a tire in my yard ♪
♪ So I make sure that I pumping the tire ♪
♪ I do it so frequently
that my brow perspires ♪
♪ I'm sweating over there ♪
♪ Then best of all, I take
it to a bachelor party ♪
♪ A blowup doll, I inflate with that ♪
♪ I put it on the
groom-to-be, he says yeah ♪
♪ You're so cool, see ♪
♪ I say, cool, I'm ice cold ♪
♪ Because I'm in Star
Wars on a real ice world ♪
♪ It's the planet Hoth,
yeah, since I was born ♪
♪ Empire Strikes Back
with a little Tauntaun ♪
♪ Cutting open the belly, crawl inside ♪
♪ All of the heat and
the warmth it provides ♪
♪ I like it, I like the winter season ♪
♪ I go to a different one,
Al-der-wrong reasons ♪
♪ I go there, get it ♪ ♪
That's an Alderaan pun ♪
♪ It existed but now it's gone ♪
♪ Like the foreskin, they blew
it up with the Death Star ♪
♪ In the third one, yeah, in Endor ♪
♪ That was a moon, it
had the little things ♪
♪ Little Ewoks on the tree, they swing ♪
♪ If you're not a geek,
if you're not a nerd ♪
♪ All of these planets that
you've never observed ♪
♪ You find it absurd, but here we go ♪
♪ I remake all the Disney movies
with characters with Afros ♪
♪ Snow White, she's got a 'fro ♪
♪ Got the little dwarves,
yeah, you need to grow ♪
♪ But then the best
one, yeah, I wanna say ♪
♪ You're dumb, y'all, if
you don't respect Rapunzel ♪
♪ She's up in the tower, sits up there ♪
♪ Takes about an hour for
her to care with her hair ♪
♪ Get a little bit of cocoa butter ♪
♪ Puts it on her skin, keeps it moist ♪
♪ Taught by your mother ♪
♪ But the Afro hair products
are more expensive ♪
♪ That's kind of weird, guys ♪
♪ We should be pensive and
think, why you set this way ♪
♪ Shops are racist, I'll
be the first to say ♪
♪ But Rapunzel, she's
up there at the window ♪
♪ Prince at the bottom,
and he's like, ho ho ♪
♪ I'm gonna climb, but
there's no follicles ♪
♪ Coming down here, 'cause
the curly molecules ♪
♪ From Afro-American hair ♪
♪ Means that the window
and the princess is there ♪
♪ And she's probably happy ♪
♪ She doesn't want a chap ♪
♪ Climbing on her hair,
ripping it out of her scalp ♪
♪ He goes up there, he
doesn't get his goal ♪
♪ He probably should have
brought a vertical pole ♪
♪ If you wanna get the
princess, that's the answer ♪
♪ When you're on your horse ♪
♪ Don't bring a lance, bring a stanchion ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)